the most common concept in almost any
coming-of-age story is finding your
passion
at such an important and tumultuous
stage in anyone's life as they come of
age deciding on what to do with your
life is understandably a topic that
resonates with almost anyone who's been
through their late teens
but i've personally never really felt
touched by this kind of story in a way
that hit home oftentimes because i feel
like the genuine emotions and themes
about life are often submerged and end
up taking a second place to other
aspects of the story like entertainment
or romance
the painstaking decisions of what to do
with yourself what to do with your life
because it isn't really all that
entertaining takes a back seat
what people love in a story is the way
it romanticizes life draws on strange
circumstances to entertain it's honestly
what i thought i enjoyed most in a story
as well
never have i felt and resonated with the
difficult decision to pursue passion
above all abandon the safe way out in
exchange for a future that is shaky and
far away
that is
until i read blue period
the beginning of your life essentially
consists of a long list of set goals to
reach
pass high school entry exams reach the
drinking age get to college even more so
in japan a society where individualism
in school is discouraged for the sake of
furthering your education
that is at least how yatora yaguchi felt
about life in his second year of high
school despite being a delinquent a
euphemism for just a student with
piercings who also smoked yaguchi is
actually a great student in school
he passes all of his classes with flying
colors and is essentially set for any
kind of future he could potentially want
to pursue in college
among his options are a salaryman or a
business worker good jobs yes but
uninspiring ones
because that is just about as far as
yaguchi's dreams extend
even though he gets good grades it's
nothing more than him putting in a bit
more time than other people he spends
his art classes sleeping and waiting
around until the last few minutes
because he knows he can get a good grade
with the minimum effort
going out with his friends he feels what
he believes is excitement
only for the night to end in the same
way every single time shrouded in the
blue haze of shibuya's morning dawn
yaguchi's life is a life without passion
in a way he is the ideal example of a
byproduct of modern society a young
student so driven to get good grades and
reach their next goal of getting into
college that once they look beyond that
they have no idea what actually keeps
them going what they're doing it all for
getting better scores and exams or
hanging out with friends are like
grinding levels in an rpg yaguchi simply
invests a bit more time than others and
he gets better results
and because of this mindset that he has
yaguchi is saddened by the idea of other
people praising him which happens more
often than not because he feels like he
is no different from anyone else and
this also pains him
and then one day he stumbles upon a
painting in the art room
it of course does not instantly have
some dramatically profound effect on him
but he's interested in its nuances
why is one green
is it a fairy was this done by another
student
but his thought process is disturbed by
the arrival of the rest of the art club
and he comes to his senses
there's no point in pursuing art art
school is unnecessarily expensive and it
supports a career path that is flaky at
best
and as yaguchi confidently starts to
leave with that mindset knowing that he
is right in his head the art teacher
offers one comment
i feel like you tried to appease your
surroundings a bit too much yaguchi
personally
i would like to know what you yourself
value
next art class show me the scenery that
you want to share with everyone else
he goes out drinking with his friends
once again later that night watching the
soccer game as per usual
but something feels off
yaguchi can't stop thinking about those
words
right now why am i shouting so hard
celebrating someone else's success
these feelings
aren't my own
yaguchi has lived a life where he just
says the things people want to hear make
their stories more interesting than his
own for the sake of just getting by
as he once again begins a day anew in
the blue morning light of shibuya he
realizes that
it's not just these feelings but this
life itself
none of it
is his
back at school yaguchi runs into the
girl who made the angel painting he saw
earlier and as they briefly discussed
the work and the effort the girl put
into it for some reason yaguchi begins
talking about shibuya
the silence the blue of it all
how that completely empty morning in the
midst of tokyo's busiest center always
feels like a moment for new beginnings
and the girl tells him something in
response to this
something that her old teacher told her
once long ago
if it looks blue to you
then anything can be blue whether it's
an apple or a rabbit
and suddenly it all clicks
the sleepy atmosphere the faintly
blinding glow that blue world
he realizes that this site is the first
that is uniquely his own one that he
wishes to express to the world
and the moment i love most in this first
chapter of this manga and arguably in
the entire series itself
as he draws that scenery he wants to
show the most yaguchi thinks
i didn't know it was so scary
to declare that you like something
and after that painting gets put on
display people look at it the same way
he saw the angel painting earlier and
they praise what he's done
why didn't i start drawing sooner
yaguchi ends the first chapter of this
series with his first step towards his
own future for the first time feeling
like he's genuinely communicated with
people
i feel like blue period with only its
first chapter could be an entire story
on its own
it fully encaptures the idea of not just
discovering your passion but embracing
it and putting it on display for others
to see
the reason i love that one line so much
that it's scary to declare that you like
something is because it truly is now
this might get personal for a moment but
i believe this is an important character
backstory for myself on why i love this
story so much
in many ways i was and still am similar
to yaguchi i was a good student in high
school and even though it came more
naturally to me than yaguchi
i didn't really have to put in that much
work it felt very similar in that there
was no real drive except to reach my
next benchmark
college exams whatever they might have
been
and aside from school my only real
passion
was anime i enjoyed occasional time with
friends going on trips but at the end of
the day the only path i pursued fully of
my own accord was watching anime
but i would say unlike nowadays in the
modern day only mere years ago anime was
not only far less mainstream than it is
now
but it was also far more scrutinized
if you declared you liked anime to the
world you either didn't care what people
thought about you or you were pretty
stupid
but just like how yaguchi had that
painting of blue shibuya
i had my breakthrough moment with this
channel with acc
making my very first video felt
liberating being able to put my thoughts
out there communicate with people who i
never would have been able to without it
it frankly changed my life
there is so much of myself that i see in
yaguchi in his pursuit of creative and
artistic passion that colors what was
previously a blank palette of a life
and i believe that is central to my love
and appreciation for this manga
but to return to the manga itself after
the first chapter yaguchi is
understandably faced with a crisis
whether he can really devote his all to
art
he's already in his second year of high
school being faced with the decision of
having to choose his college that he's
going to apply to on top of that the
entrance exams for art universities are
incredibly rigorous and selective making
the odds that a complete beginner
getting in no matter how passionate they
are
slim to none
thoughts reappear in his head isn't
drawing for a hobby enough
i can draw even if i don't go to art
school
why should i take it seriously
if he continues down this risky path he
sacrifices this position he's cemented
academically at the top of the social
ladder
he's going to have to start everything
over once again with no checkpoints
along the way
taking that leap
isn't it scary but teacher to the rescue
she once again offers new words of
advice for yaguchi
upon asking her whether drawing for just
a hobby is enough expressing what he's
thinking she tells him that kids who
can't work hard are those that don't
have any passion
after all it is only natural to invest
your life on things that you are most
passionate about
again only two chapters into this manga
i truly feel the words behind it
even now youtube isn't my only pursuit i
still go to school because at this point
in my life
i can't and wouldn't bring myself to
devote fully to my creative pursuits
i'm not even as brave as yaguchi it's
it's terrifying to declare you like
something and then continue on to devote
yourself to it entirely
blue period embraces a topic that is
equally inspiring
and
horrifying and i think my favorite
moment of this manga encompasses this
perfectly it isn't some grand
achievement or win for yaguchi a
breakthrough in his art not at all
my favorite moment is only in chapter
five
when he tells his mom that he wants to
pursue art
as i was mentioning earlier yaguji is a
product of modern society
passions are a hobby and a side project
to pure academics and his mom is an
example of that ideal
despite his dad's encouraging words to
pursue his dream yaguchi's mom remains
on the fence she spent her entire life
raising her son pushing him to do better
and the possibility of throwing that all
away for possibly a pipe dream is
understandably something that even i as
a parent wouldn't encourage so lightly
and when she asked him why he wanted to
do this
yaguchi couldn't think of a reason
perfectly befitting of his enjoyment of
art words weren't enough to describe how
he felt
so he drew a picture of his mom for her
and in his time watching his mom making
that picture he saw how her hands were
rough from always washing their dishes
how her forearms had muscle from lifting
heavy groceries daily
how food rotates between the same dishes
every day but every time
she always eats the worst parts of the
meat
as he drew and observed his mother he
realized how everything she ever did
was for the well-being of their family
something he never would have noticed if
he stayed the same mindlessly droning on
in school in pursuit of his next
benchmark
even if he didn't have any talent at all
all he needed was her support i think
that this is such a beautiful moment of
self-recognition for yaguchi and for
anyone in pursuit of their dreams
even if yaguchi isn't good at it even if
he's not the best it's what he loves as
a youtuber there are millions upon
millions of channels that i can watch
who have more subscribers or better
editing or better scripts it is
impossible not to compare myself to
others who might be growing faster
and i think what blue period taught me
is that
that doesn't matter
what matters is your enjoyment your life
and the hope that other people can see
what you value in it
one of the most discouraging things that
someone can experience in life is doing
something they love to the best of their
abilities but still not being good at it
constantly looking at others only to
realize how much your abilities pale in
comparison
it makes it feel like your efforts
aren't worth it at all and that is one
of the scariest things you can encounter
on a one-way road where you only have
yourself to fall back on that's why
gyaguchi needed his mother's support
and i think that this idea of embracing
that you are just normal is one of the
greatest parts of blue period
fast forward a bit and yaguchi enters
art cram school to prepare himself for
art university entrance exams
it's his first time working on art
outside of his school's small and rather
unnoticed art club but even though he
feels slightly intimidated more than
anything he's excited
he draws the sculpture that they're
supposed to but once they finish and the
class compare the drawing that yaguchi
initially felt somewhat proud of
soon gets overshadowed by the works
surrounding him
a silent cry lashed out from within him
[Music]
most notably the work of takahashi next
to him is perfect the shapes the shadows
the balance
it makes sergi realize the difference
between genius and hard work
it's always something he accepted about
himself from the start of the story it's
a continuous thought he always has that
he was just simply working harder than
everyone else
but never has it felt more clear than
now
that he's just a normal human
i'm sure that everyone at some point in
their life has felt this way when seeing
the achievements of someone else feeling
like it's unachievable
but once again in the catalogue of
quotes offered to yaguchi for advice
this time from a friend of his he says
if you're upset
then that means you're willing to fight
yaguchi's fight has only just begun of
course he'd be intimidated but why
should he let someone else's
achievements stop him
i just think that the story of blue
period is so incredibly profound in its
subtlety
nothing feels too extraordinary too
romanticized or too unrealistic for the
sake of making a more interesting tale
it's rooted in the real and challenging
pursuit
of your passions
every piece of art we see in the story
is drawn by a real artist that the
mangaka wanted to include in the manga
she gives credit to each of them in each
chapter so you can tell how grounded
this story is in what is ultimately just
love for art
we also learn about the challenges of
going to college and the way that
academic success has been put on such a
high pedestal that for some reason just
doing what you enjoy is made to feel
wrong like you're betraying society by
following your dreams
that is the notion that blue period
challenges in its story and it's one
that is incredibly touching especially
to a youtuber like myself
i feel like at one point or another
within the last year i have felt just
about everything yaguchi has felt as
well in this story
feeling afraid to declare what you like
dedicating your all to a craft that
might have no fruitful end in sight
seeing yourself as just normal or less
than others among a group of incredibly
talented artists
for anyone who has passions that they
aren't able to express or pursue of
their own accord for whatever reason
self-imposed or because of rules outside
of your control
blue period is the manga for you
if you've let that opportunity to change
your future past you then perhaps blue
period can remind you of that excitement
you once felt and you can live
vicariously through yaguchi and his
journey through the intimidating world
of art
if you're too young to be at that point
maybe this story can inspire you to make
sure that whatever you do from now on is
for the purpose of living the life you
want to have so you don't start late
like yaguchi
and if you feel like you are there now
at that crossroads where you must decide
what you want to do with your future
like myself
i believe that blue period can inspire
you to make the choice that you want
after all to once again draw on the
quotes from this series
it's only natural to invest your life on
the thing you are most passionate about
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like and subscribe
for future in-depth show manga and
character analyses
you